maddie's got a girl with a red flag
that he's thinking about marrying all
right
all right what do you got what do you
got hey bro
what's shaking i'm fine thank you how
are you it's a red flag
okay i've known her since a year okay
or year and a half um
as i got got to know her she turned out
to have
she turned out to have daddy issues her
dad cheated or cheated on her mom
and he didn't divorce her he just left
her there living
at her parents house
she's super super super jealous
today actually um something happened we
were having dinner
we were breaking fast because it's
ramadan in egypt
and i wanted to show her some photo on
my phone
she saw that photo of me and that chick
uh at the presentation we were having so
she
just got silent and uh
she she she just she just sat there
saying nothing i just tried to make a
conversation but
but she kept saying short answers and
she left
and now and half an hour later she
called me and she started crying like a
little kid
crying
crying about you you uh you you like you
got traitor you treated me
you you cheated on me if put yourself in
my shoes imagine if you saw me with a
guy
what would you do what would you do um
saying another check or was it just a
picture of you with another check no no
just a picture a normal picture and a
presentation she
she's got some trauma from her childhood
because she because she watched her
mom you know tortured by the fact that
her old man was smashing some other
check which by the way from what i
understand is pretty common with muslim
culture isn't it
uh actually you know you don't get in
muslim cultures we don't get to bang
you you you only get to have sex after
married with
wives i mean so you can take on more
than one wife but you're not supposed to
be banging outside of that marriage got
it okay
precisely okay so
she watched her mom suffer and now
anything
that remotely resembles what might lead
up to that suffering that she
that she saw is why she's spazzing out
right now
that's not your problem that's her
problem and
what you have to basically say is don't
make your problems my problems if you
have trauma from your childhood
go deal with it find a therapist and go
sort it out
because i'm not going to go through the
rest of my life involved with a check
that's constantly going to be monitoring
me like a predator drone
i have that in my red flag chapter if
you guys
um i'll throw the banner up so you can
get it for free but
yeah so it's in the book but i mean if
you don't want to buy the book for
whatever reason
you can get the red flag flag chapter
here by opting into my email list
entrepreneursandcars.com forward slash
red dash flags
and jealous women is in that chapter
i've i've dealt with my share of jealous
women in my past
and i said in the chapter they're like a
predator drone
they're going to monitor everything that
you do they're going to drive by your
place when
when they're not coming over that night
to see whose car is in the driveway
they're going to count your condoms
they're going to be looking for
girls you know fingerprints on your
glass shower door in your mirror
dude they're going to go through your
private [ __ ] like they're going to go
through your boxes
and they're going to find a stack of
photographs from a girl that you dated
maybe 10 years ago just because you keep
your photographs in one area
and then she's going to make some big
[ __ ] deal about it how you have a
[ __ ] shrine to some ex-girlfriend and
and just like spaz out about it this is
not that uncommon
i saw it quite a few times you know in
my life dating
uh chicks and ltrs that i had as well
and it's [ __ ] exhausting and i can
tell you right now a man
at my age i would never tolerate that
again
so how old are you i'm 26.
save yourself the [ __ ] and set that
boundary right now
okay and if like is this a chick that
you're dating like have you claimed each
other you guys are monogamous
like what's the story uh we're both
working at the same place
uh uh she and i um
like what we met at the we started
chatting a little bit
we became friends and the thing
escalated she
she it confessed her love to me at the
at the beginning she obviously thinks
that you guys are monogamous because
she's getting pissed off
by even just a photograph that she comes
across in your phone
right yes so are you being monogamous
with her
uh by monogamous you mean i don't have
other other choices
sexually exclusive of course not no
okay so you need to be clear to her then
you need to let her know
i don't believe in monogamy i'm i'm
seeing other women
um you know if she's your main girl and
you want to claim her as
you know like your main check fine do
that but at least like
set that boundary so you don't have to
deal with a clandestine [ __ ]
right because that's what's you know
what's going to end up happening she's
always going to be up your ass about
something
you're going to have to behave in a
suspicious manner you're going to have
to
you know it's going to be cloak and
dagger you're going to have to work
behind the scenes
i mean if that's what you want to do at
least be honest about it and say look
you know
wednesday nights is my night to smash
strange so
you can't come around that's what i'm
doing you're just gonna have to accept
that's you know
that's what i'm doing but the rest of
the time i'm all yours i'm not gonna
embarrass you
i'm not gonna bring strange by
restaurants that we go to together
i'm not gonna embarrass your family i'm
not gonna rub it in your face i'm not
gonna post pictures of any strange
like you have to like basically break it
down like that and if she's okay with
that you move on but i can tell you
right now a chick like that is not going
to be okay with it
in the future after even if i married
her
this this chick if she doesn't deal with
the fact that you're
non-monogamous is going to be on you
like a fat kid on cake
she's never gonna let up she will make
your life
a living nightmare if you get married to
her i can tell you right now
ouch even if she is super obedient
she's not super obedient because she
doesn't stay in your frame
she sees a picture of you with another
chick and she spazzes out
she literally does everything i say i i
say come come to meet me right now she
comes
do that she does it don't do that she
she takes permission
uh even if she wanted to go out with her
girls she says
maddie should i go if i said yes yes no
no good so okay so she's in your frame
in all other areas with the exception
you know the fact that
you don't want to be sexually monogamous
to to her
exactly so just tell her that that's
that's who i am
that's what i'm going to be and if you
have a problem with that you can go date
some other [ __ ]
oh god see but you can only do that if
you come from a place of abundance
right you can only do that if you're
okay with letting her walk
i told i actually did give gave that
gave that to her face i told her
um you're not exclusive i can date other
women if you
if you're not okay with me you can go i
don't give a [ __ ]
good that's all that that's all that you
have to do then you just have to hold
that position firm
right and if she goes she goes but if
she's gonna stay
there's no more you know surveillance
there's no more you know
uh crocodile tear you know cry fest over
what are you doing on wednesday night
you know who's this uh
who's this girl that keeps liking all
your pictures on social media
yes right because that's what they'll do
like they'll start creeping the [ __ ] out
of you like they'll look at your social
media posts
they'll see who likes them they'll look
at the comments and then they'll try and
put two
and then they'll start messaging them
hey hey you look familiar you look like
a girl that i went to university with
you know do we know each other
and then like try to like cause dude
jealous women it's either comply or
goodbye
if she's not going to comply with the
rules that you sat and the way that you
want to run the relationship with her
it's goodbye there's there's other women
out there that will fall into your frame
okay there's other women out there
that'll be okay with maddie you know
spinning some plates from time to time
on the side as long as you don't embarra
like
general rule is you don't embarrass her
you don't bring strange to like
nightclubs restaurants
you don't do like overnight dates you
know with them or anything like that
you know you generally don't want to
embarrass her right like if you look at
the model that
most of europe uses especially around
the mediterranean it's very different
from north america like north america
when it comes to
that sort of activity is i'm going to
declare monogamy
but in a clandestine way i'm going to be
adulterous
esther perel talks about that in her
books that's the way they run it in
north america
in europe it's like okay you know my
husband's at work
and he comes home at eight o'clock and i
know between you know
five and eight he does whatever he does
as long as he doesn't embarrass me he
doesn't
you know put any risks to the family to
the children there's no money that's
being taken like there's still food in
my kid's mouth
and then and then they just look the
other way right
queen elizabeth a classic example looked
the other way
several times when prince philip was
smashed and strange on the side
she found out about it she just looked
this is the queen of england
okay oh my god women are okay to share a
high value alpha
in egypt we can't women a man get to
marry
on up to four women in egypt in muslim
and muslim cultures
right you get to marry four i know dude
i was i was talking to craig from um
abu american and you know he's telling
me about all the wives that he's had
dude's had 12 wives i think he's got two
or three right now
i would not want more than one wife like
like i can't fathom living with
four [ __ ] women like why like why
would you bring that
especially with modern women today like
could you like one modern woman's enough
yeah
you know you put four in the mix forget
about it [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] anyway did that help you out
exactly exactly thank you so much thank
you so much okay
good good thanks man all right um
chris chris has some interesting
comments here i saw how pop-up
were they women women only want to see
multiple men in response to a man seeing
multiple women
true uh it's a tactic to try and get him
out to commit and be monogamous also
true
tiger woods wife looked the other way
for years it wasn't until she was
embarrassed on a global scale that she
had a problem with it
to my point exactly to my point exactly
okay if if you're gonna
do something outside of the relationship
let her know that you're doing it
but also let her know that you're not
going to embarrass her that you're not
going to go out of your way
to make her look bad or to put her
health at risk or to take
you know food out of your children's
mouth or to take a roof off the family's
head
i've talked to a lot of guys on consults
in various stages of their relationships
whether they're getting married they're
married or they're getting divorced
talked to several guys whose wives just
looked the other way they didn't care
they didn't care as long as the kids
were and the household was take
taken care of and she wasn't exposed to
any kind of disease or anything like
that
fine do what you got to do go make bank
chase excellence be a good father i
don't care
you